I did oh-hey clong what's up are you uh
are you wearing beats by dre right now
with the yeah yeah they are I decided to
give another chance okay
yeah I feel like with all the hate
towards beats by dre we just kind of
started dismissing them without even
really giving them a shot so I think
that's not as fair so you can start
using beats like full time and
everything well no I mean okay so these
are the Beats Studio 2.0 so I'm giving
them a fair listen alright so how does
it sound like like beats
they sound like beats but honestly
that's that's not even really the point
about you know that's not really the
point of Beats oh yeah yeah it's not I
mean let's be real people aren't really
buying these for the way they sound
beats by dre I have this reputation in
the audio lovers community of being
overpriced and sounding like garbage
compared to other headphones in the same
price bracket and that's true but that's
also not really the point of these
headphones and it's no secret either
margins that's the difference between
the cost it is to actually physically
make something and what you actually end
up selling it for now you need this gap
to make money profit obviously but you
also need this gap to make up for other
costs you might have besides
manufacturer every device has margins
take a phone for example the Samsung
Galaxy s5 costs about $250 in parts to
manufacture but it retails outright for
around $600 so this gap is used to make
up for other cost Samsung has in
research and advertising and then some
profit headphones have the same thing
the difference between the cost of parts
and the eventual retail cost for audio
Technica's and 50s for example is made
mostly of research testing in some
packaging not a lot of advertising and
that also may be why you've never heard
of audio technica beats on the other
hand will also spend on research and
testing but they go to the next level
with packaging and advertising first of
all beats by dre packaging is I think
easily the best and any headphones out
there no shame in admitting that they're
just the
best package the presentation the colors
the imagery the accessories you get
inside everything about the unboxing
experience of a pair of beats by dre
Trump's anything Audio Technica has ever
done and they spend money to do that but
really it's about the advertising you've
heard of beats by dre and your mom and
dad probably have too but if you ask
them to name another audio company they
might have some trouble unless they're
an audio head and this is because beats
by dre spends a lot of money on
advertising on endorsements and getting
their name out there and getting their
product in front of everyone's eyes
before beats believe it or not there
really was no such thing as a musician
endorsing audio products the same way we
have basketball players endorsing shoes
they were the first to do this and it
all started with dr dre himself
legendary producer he's made music right
so if he puts his name on these
headphones well it must be good right
even if you don't believe that there are
custom beats with Justin Bieber's name
on them with Lady Gaga's name on them
nicki minaj you see other musicians
wearing them all the time Skrillex
will.i.am David Guetta Lil Wayne they
all show beats in their music videos and
they all wear them at live performances
even celebrities who aren't musicians
there are tons of athletes who were
beats by dre in public all the time
LeBron James Kobe Bryant Tom Brady
Serena Williams but none of this is free
beats by dre pays for obviously they pay
for the music video product placement
but they're also just giving away custom
pairs of beats by dre all the time to
celebrities so they appear as you know
fashion statements on the red carpet
they show up at events all the time
these guys are geniuses at getting beats
by dre to appear alongside people's
favorite celebrities so just like that
young basketball player buying his idols
shoes young kids everywhere buying beats
by dre because they saw it alongside
their favorite celebrity or at an event
or in a tweet and it's working of the
multi-million dollar premium headphone
industry of headphones that cost a
hundred dollars or more
beats by dre owns sixty four percent of
that market beats sixty four percent of
the expensive headphones that people are
buying our beats by dre clearly it's
working perceived value is really the
name of the game that Beats Electronics
is winning the more people think you're
product is worth the more they're
willing to pay for it and with the
celebrities wearing them all over the
place all the time the design the
fashion statement it makes the premium
unboxing experience even the custom
spots in stores all over the country
that's separated from the rest that's
why they're able to charge $300 for
these when I'd be willing to bet they
cost less than a hundred and fifty
dollars to make and that's the truth
about beats by dre now don't get me
wrong beats aren't the only ones with an
inflated perceived value I mean
Skullcandy also comes to mind but again
it's that 64% Beats is doing a great job
people are buying beats all over the
place and they're winning at this game
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
but just here's my bottom line knowing
all this knowing all you know about
margins and perceived value you know
that a $300 pair of headphones is not
necessarily twice as good as a hundred
and fifty dollar pair of headphones in
fact it probably isn't especially if the
$300 pair is spending so much on
marketing and their image so if you're
going to buy a pair of headphones and
all you care about is not just the
fashion but the design and the unboxing
experience and the name and the
reputation of the company then beats by
dre are great and the Audio Technica m50
suck I mean what is that but if all you
care about when buying these headphones
is the sound and the frequency response
and the accuracy and you care less about
the name and the brand image then the
Audio Technica m50 s are great and beats
by dre suck so when you're going to
spend money on upgrading headphones pick
your budget and then pick what you
actually want to buy do you want to buy
sound or not and that's how you make
your decision that's been it thanks for
watching hope you enjoyed and hey feel
free to share this video with other
people who may want to know about the
truth of beats by dre feel free to embed
this as well hit me up on Twitter if you
have any questions or the comments
section below thank you for watching and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you